all right janelle
janelle where'd you grow up where are
you from virginia fairbanks alaska
alaska yep and uh tell me about your
childhood you had both your parents as a
kid
um well not really i had my mom and my
grandparents
my dad was out of the picture by the
time i was six
how would you describe your childhood my
childhood was really good
i was raised with horses and i did a lot
of dancing and gymnastics
and swimming and then uh my mom met
my stepdad and pulled us away from all
of that
and moved us to anchorage and
i did not like that i didn't like that
at all and um i left home at 13
after that we did some ballroom dancing
before that you know ballroom and
dancing and stuff and it wasn't my thing
so what was going on that made you leave
home at 13.
i was really upset they took me away
from my horses in fairbanks
so then i got into the drugs with all
the kids at school you know
started with pot and then acid then i
left home with my boyfriend
and that's when everything went
really bad i was growing up in alaska is
it cold
really cold i'm sure it's cold but is it
are there are drugs pretty
common down there that's all there is to
do that's all there is to
there's nothing else to do hmm so
then you and your boyfriend went where
oh on the street
his mom was a um a crack [ __ ]
and she real quickly turned me out so by
the time i was 13 i was
prostituting and using crack cocaine
and then from there i was
i prostituted till i was 21
and then on and off the streets
and i don't know life life has just been
hard
like when i was eight i was molested by
my camp counselor
and uh i don't remember that though
i've just been told about it i guess it
was pretty bad
but um i don't know i've just been on
and off the streets
since since then did you finish school
no
how far did you go eight ninth grade
two weeks into my ninth grade year
and today you're home i'm 44. 44. do you
have kids
yeah i have three daughters and where
are they they're in fairbanks
who's raising them uh they're all grown
all except for my youngest she's 15. her
dad has her
and so did you raise your kids um
no no my
two oldest were raised by my
grandparents
and my mom and my youngest
was between me and her dad
so prostitution was the way you were
surviving for
for a long time for a long time i still
do once in a while
yeah yeah so today you're on skid row
yeah and how
you're still using drugs i take it yeah
what's your drug today
heroin
and this is a rough life as well right
oh yeah
too rough is it rougher here and skid
row than uh then
no alaska no this is way easier way
easier the weather's easier
yeah it's not 60 below zero
so this is kind of nice actually it's a
nice change
and how long have you been here two
weeks oh you're brand new
yeah from where from fairbanks oh from
alaska yeah oh wow
had never been out of alaska until now
so la must be a nice
nice wonderful change
it's dangerous here too as well though
yeah yeah
i've had a couple scares
but so tell me what happened between
those years
so in your 30s and 40s you were doing
what
well i actually was doing okay in my 30s
and 40s i bought a piece of property
and owned a home it burned down
how did you afford to i only had to pay
8 000 for the property so i
worked a little bit with my grandparents
and
some other things to uh make the money
and bought the property put a double
white trailer on there
and uh ended up getting pregnant
having my daughter and three days after
we moved into the home
it burned down with us in it and uh so
that was pretty scary
but we we got out thank god barely but
we got out
and then we put another trailer up and
i've been struggling to survive there
up until now i couldn't do it no more so
i sold the place and left
so if you could put your finger on one
thing that kind of led to your
spiraling downward drugs drugs
all the way not the molestation when you
were young
oh that could be it i just don't
remember it
i've been told about it by several
people i've i've seen the paperwork
i'm the only one out of 22 kids that
testified and i guess it took a couple
years
i remember i remember the court going
going to see the judges and everything
there was like 12 judges
around the table that i had to sit there
in front of with a doll and tell them
what happened
i don't remember what i told them um i
do remember leaving
and my lawyer gave me a kitten but
that's about all i remember of that
a horrible thing yeah the paperwork said
it was pretty bad
this is really bad did you sell contact
with your family
yeah your kids yeah yeah
yeah my middle daughter doesn't like me
too much but
my other kids like me all right
what's the worst part of this lifestyle
for you living on the street drugs
prostitution all that not being with my
kids
having to struggle all the time did you
have dreams as a kid of doing something
with your life
oh yeah yeah i wanted to be
i don't want it to be anything i thought
i was going to be a professional
horseback rider you know dressage and
stuff like that
but it didn't go that way
and do you have friends oh yeah i've got
a lot of friends
but none of them any good
you ever been in love oh yeah too many
times
in fact i'm trying to
i guess i'm in a relationship still in
fairbanks
kind of he thinks i'm coming back i'm
not
so that's hard that's really hard
what do you worry about what do i worry
about surviving another day
it's hard out here
do you see that the family that you grew
up in might have
set the path for this all that happened
or your family was pretty solid well
they were when i was younger
and then they got really weird and
everything just really fell apart when
my mom took us away from my grandparents
and it fell apart really bad my
grandparents really turned out to be
not who they were i mean they're mean
they're
extremely mean and nasty now to the
grandkids
some something must have been off for a
13 year old to go out in the street
yeah and not finished school i
absolutely
hated the fact that my mom took me away
from my horses
i hated her for that i still do
i don't hate her for it but i definitely
am
still pissed and how do you feel all
these years on the street and
doing questionable things for money has
changed you
it's turned me into a lot harder of a
person i'm not
nearly as nice as i probably could be
i don't trust anybody anymore trust must
be a big issue yeah
it's a huge issue everyone down here is
a snake yeah
i get sick of being groped constantly by
the men down here you know
it's irritating right
did you still have hope for your future
not really
no i'm pretty much guessing this is
about how it's going to be
i don't see much else happening
i'm a little too old to come up
at all i i feel i don't see any
big sums of money happening you know
so we'll lose your lowest point
my lowest point is probably right now
being down here with absolutely nothing
no car no home just my sister
it's hard no money no food
no nothing
what's the most important lesson you've
learned to stay the [ __ ] away from drugs
i wish i could get away from them
i hate them tell me about alaska i mean
it seems like
there must be a rough it's cold there
it's really really cold if you don't
have a place to live you're screwed
there's no way you can live on the
streets there you have to either couch
hop
or go to a shelter if there's an
available bed
if not you're living in your car and you
better hope you have gas because if not
you're gonna freeze to death
in the winter anyway literally yeah
literally yeah
60 below zero is no joke
what do you think was the
the basis of your mom's what do you
think do you do you see your mom is just
being selfish
and taking you away from what you love
well she was addicted to drugs really
bad when i was younger so she was an
addict as well yeah
and then she got clean and met my
stepdad
and my stepdad swept her off her feet
and he what he said went
and he wanted to move to anchorage and
so that's what we did
and i wasn't very happy with that at all
and heroin down here i mean the quality
of it is probably
questionable right it's not very good i
have to say the stuff in fairbanks is
better
by far which is strange i thought it
would be better here it's not though
not at all
and where do you see your life going i
mean you've already
mentioned that maybe you're stuck and
this will be it
yeah i hope not i mean i i'm hoping
i'm hoping i just got accepted for the
unemployment
so i'm hoping maybe i can get an
apartment or something like that
but i don't know and then maybe find a
job
i don't know with this covent thing who
knows
yeah it's kind of screwing everything up
and is does that affect your work if
you're dating guys that must
pay time big time because you're your
potential clients out there yeah a lot
of calls quit coming in
there's a lot of people are scared yeah
so yeah
not very much money in it right now yeah
everyone's scrambling for
a buck right now yeah
all right janelle well thank you so much
for sharing your story yeah i wish you
the best of luck
thank you welcome to la thanks welcome
to hell yeah
we skid row yeah it definitely is